77 year-old Joy Behar is taking time off
from the view I decided that I think I'm
gonna stay home for a while I'm gonna
socially distance myself a little bit
but I'm in a high-risk group because of
my age right but I'm perfectly healthy I
know Wendy Williams heir to repeat today
after previously filling empty audience
seats with staffers the show now telling
et production will be put on hold
indefinitely
[Applause]
Colbert Fallon and Kimmel are following
suit suspending production entirely
until April Corden is expected to go on
without audiences we want to take a
minute to say just know that you are you
are not alone we love you so much and
we're gonna be here every night trying
to make you laugh and trying to bring a
bit of light and levity into your day
whenever we can films including fast and
furious 9 have delayed opening and
primetime TV is affected as well there's
a ton of precautions being taken you
just got to Warner Brothers has halted
70 plus pilots in series including the
Bachelorette all of NBC's Chicago dramas
CBS's NCIS franchise and ABC's Grey's
Anatomy have shut down production I am a
child and I and I like Disneyland Disney
parks are both shutting down but Disney
World was packed today before it closes
on Sunday it's really quiet here in
Times Square
Broadway's dark and musicians are
scrapping concerts we had to cancel it's
a scary time for a lot of people a
fearful lizzo sanitized before leading a
mass meditation live on Instagram she
nixed her Houston show Billy Joel
postpone dates as did Diana Ross and
Mariah Mimi did perform proper
hand-washing for her kids on tick-tock
Hanabi was set to start March 24th on
the Dancing with the Stars tour that's
canceled The Bachelor Live hopes to
resume April 20th what goes down here
why do we have these curtains Oh Lauren
if only you
you know word on how social distancing
could change the fantasy suite part of
the production 80% of the people on
stage who have participated the fantasy
suites have kissed at this point Wow
[Music]